health secretary you said recently it's
up to us to have a debate
as a nation about where we go next with
the vaccine
rollout identifying priority groups how
do you
identify who needs a vaccine more
urgently
between a police officer a shop worker
or a teacher and the second question can
i have your response
to dr ted ross from the world health
organization who said
as far as the the global distribution of
this vaccine is concerned we're
witnessing
a catastrophic moral failure
uh thank you so i'll ask um
susan hopkins to come in on the uh on
the first
part of that question but it is
essentially
the clinical the clinical advice
is to go through the top four groups and
then through
uh five groups five to nine which takes
you to the over 50s
and then after that it is essentially
about
protecting people as well as possible
um according to um essentially a
a judgment about who we think who should
come next
that's why i think we should have a
debate about it because
99 of the deaths occur in the top
nine groups i mentioned in the in my
opening comments 88 percent
are covered in the top four 99 in the
top
nine so after that it really is about
protecting against
uh transmission and making sure that we
can get life
back to normal uh as much as possible
susan yeah absolutely so just to
reiterate those discussions happen with
the joint committee for vaccination
and immunizations and we look at a range
of
figures there so deaths clearly
hospitalizations next
and then transmission and i think one of
the important points is is that we're
learning
how well and will continue to learn how
well this vaccine
will protect against transmission and
that knowledge will help inform the next
decision-making process
because clearly then you may target
groups that are transmitting more than
others are
out there and working if it isn't
working for transmission then i think we
need to continue to
target the groups at the highest risk of
hospitalization and those are the older
age groups
thank you and then on the second part of
your question
i was in communication with dr tedros
over the weekend and
the uk is the world's biggest
supporter financial supporter of the
global program to ensure access to
vaccines in
all countries in the world through
organizations like
sepi and kovacs so not only have we
developed in partnership with the uh
with the um our scientists at
oxford and astrazeneca we've developed
what is currently the most cost
effective vaccine that is available
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine we've
also put the most
financial support into these
international efforts to ensure
everybody has
access to vaccine so i absolutely
agree with dr tedros on the importance
of a global rollout and
we in the uk can be proud of what we are
doing
to support that happening financially
and i look forward to working with the
world health organization
and others including in seppi kovacs and
other organizations
to try to make sure that we get enough
of vaccine
to be able to vaccinate the whole world
and certainly the whole
world's adult population for which
vaccines are now approved